ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we are always grateful to
have you here with us tuning in my voice
uh raspy as always here with no smoking
for months and months and months and
still the rasp but it's not cigarettes
and I don't think it ever was I think
it's um I think it is
dairy that's I think the that's what I
figured out not smoking cigarettes that
the real killer so to
speak da there was a book called milk
some type of killer but that's we're not
doing that that's not where we're going
The Noose is tightening I don't know if
I can even is that allowed that one The
Noose is tightening probably not but the
Noose is tightening I'm using it for
Arizona white Suburban kids so that's
okay but there is a noose and it is
tightening on the next
of the Gilbert goons the story that we
talked about we broke on this
show we broke the story of the Gilbert
goons in Arizona and I was the one
leading the charge to try to get Justice
for this sad this poor child who was
killed and I was uh leading the TR but
also let's give credit where credit is
due to the people of Arizona I made fun
of them lightly jokingly and they have
actually stood up they've risen up and
they've demanded Justice and they forced
the police
department that was seemingly cover
covering this up at the very least the
police department didn't seem as
motivated as they should have been and
then there were all these theories about
the parents and the school and the
Mormon Temple and I I don't know what's
what
um now this group of people we know is
largely suburban and white although one
of them is black maybe there's a few of
them that are black
but the was it the New York Post that
decided to put the black guy like the
one or two black guys this group again
largely white middle you know upper
middle class Rich if you want to by the
standards of Arizona and the New York
Post look at this affluent uh members of
an affluent Arizona
gang busted in string of caught on video
attacks on high schoolers but who do
they who do they have here for the uh
front page we
have a black
guy on the front
page of the
newspaper and there's no pictures of any
of the white people so
people tend to get maybe
confused the black guy's name is Mr
Fantastic which
again is not helping that doesn't help
anybody um but more white kids are going
down it it is more of a white thing than
it is a a black thing but it is the New
York Post so they saw an afro and they
said hey we're going we're goingon to
we're running with that we're going to
run with that but hey if this guy's
involved he's got everybody's got to get
caught
that does the wrong thing in that part
of
Arizona so there's all these theories
lurid theories about the parents in
Costa Rica and who's hiding who and you
go on the reddits and you read and you
go on next door and you read and people
have and all these kids names are like
brilin and TN and jayen and it's all
silly and ridiculous and you don't know
what's what and who's who and then the
one of the kids' mothers seems to be in
it and she's writing well he
didn't show me proof that he killed
anyone and everyone's like we know
you're his mother in the Reddit they're
like we you're his mother and she's like
no I don't even know him but
again show me the proof that he killed
and it's like such weird mom energy that
it's got to be the
mom and what a weird time and it's a
boomer probably or or someone younger
than a
boomer but it's just funny like the idea
that you're on a
Reddit
thread defending your
son from the charge of murder
to the local community on a Reddit
thread hiding behind an
avatar well why don't you show me the
proof that he show me one photo DM me
the
proof and people are like hey and people
are laying out the case and she's like
arguing and it's like why would you care
that much who cares that much it's got
to be the
mom or maybe it's somebody the mom knows
or something and then there's people out
there that are like maybe the moms are
out there spreading
disinfo like spreading
disinformation on these and I'm trying
to buy the IP I call CAA I call these
people you know and I called them I go
give me the intellectual property rights
to this story it's my [__] story if
there's a movie about this so help me
God this is my story
legitimately and I want Justice for the
kid th% and I want intellectual property
rights to a Netflix thing as well on
this from legit I'm telling my i' I've
texted my agent that I want the
intellectual property rights this wres
itself I get ignored in this town
Hollywood not the town I'm in now which
is New York but I'm also kind of ignored
here as well some of the people I would
like to pay attention to me but I'm
ignored in this town cuz I'm always
pitching
myselfself which is uh not always easily
digestible but I go in there with white
Suburban kids Mormons killing in the
streets the cops covering up this is the
story I've wanted to pitch my entire
life I go in there I go I'm a fat [__]
and I like Trump a little bit I mean I'm
thrown out I get thrown out that's not
what you do no one want who's that who's
buying that who's buying that I got all
these you know these lovely people
lovely lovely lovely Jewish people in
the rooms staring at
me I'm always like someone's wife's
favorite someone's crazy wife who they
like can't bring the cocktail party they
stash her in Palm Beach they're always
like my wife loves you she's down at
Palm Beach she's given to
spells we put her down at Palm Beach she
tells me you're great but we can't I
mean we can't write you any checks here
we can't be involved we can't do
anything with you but this time I'm
going in and I can tell their eyes are
going to roll when I walk in because
some but they enjoy me as a as some type
of novelty I'm a fun break in the day to
a lot of these Executives thank God I
have the good people here the public
which is supports
me you know but I would go in and their
eyes are going to roll they're going to
go yeah yeah yeah we get it we get it we
get it we get it we get get fat [__]
Trump blah blah blah I go not this time
this time I have white Suburban
kids a police cover up rich people and
desert Landscapes which you [__] love
you people love shooting things in the
desert am I right am I right okay Sasha
or Yale or any of these names who I'm
pitching Ben or Yale or Sasha or you
know did you see that New York Times get
this New York Times article Because by
the way I love me some Israel and some
Palestine and I'm the only one that has
the balls to say
it I'm the only one who has the balls to
say it I want everyone to thrive and
prosper
okay the New York Times has this article
that come out with this
article we all know the bombing campaign
uh in uh Gaza has been has been
insane the loss of life is tremendous
there's nothing like it Andrew Sullivan
uh in a piece on his blog called it
infanticide it's hard to argue with that
a genocide is means a deliberate uh you
know wiping out of a
race that's certainly a different charge
that's in the ha and people are debating
that
I'm not we're not debating genocide
today we're trying to have a nice time
of it I just got back from Palm Beach
what I'm saying is when you are killing
large amounts of children
indiscriminately infanticide does seem
somewhat
appropriate so there's a lot of stuff
going on here a lot of
stuff and in the front page of the New
York Times we have scope and quality of
Gaza tunnels all Israelis a network is
LA is 450 mil that has over 5,000 shafts
now okay okay that's a piece of
news and we get that Hamas has tunnels
but the tremendous bombing campaign the
insane loss of life and
dislocation uh of peoples and things
like
that and now that this is written you
gota folks you gota I mean just for a
little on I get it but have a little
just have one Gentile write the thing
because here's the who's written this
article by the way on when by the way
everybody's protesting I can barely get
to my show in DC because of these
protests they're in New York they're
everywhere they're in La they're in
every major city massive protests
Biden's poll numbers are crashing
they're calling him genocide Joe it's a
it's a nightmare for the Democratic
party especially among young young
people scope and quality of Gaza tunnels
a Israelis now what's funny about this
headline is that the scope of the
bombing is awing many people too right
around the world that's also awing
people this article is written by Adam
Goldman Ronan
Bergman and gal klewitz it's like and
then uh Patrick Kings
we throw in the genti guys I mean I
understand but just in the idea of
objectivity throw in uh uh a billy
O'Brien throw in uh Tommy ianucci in
there this article about the Hamas
tunnels was written by Tommy ianucci and
Billy
obrian instead of this is almost like in
Windy City Heat Sal Stein bertz the
character of the agent whose name is
solstein bertz Windy City Heat he goes
God I got really [__] solstein beroit
[__] me this is kind of the vibe of
that a little bit I'm just saying throw
in something a little different throw in
a Tommy Perez Perez Lopez something
something little
different but I'm saying I want this IP
for this story because it is my story
that I own that I've brought attention
to and that finally I could go in to
these companies with something that
[__] for Christ they might make cuz
it's rich white people being uh
murderers in the b in the desert
landscape nice desert landscape purple
sunsets it's uh kids on dirt bikes it's
their mothers everybody's there covering
it up they own a gym or whatever I'm not
saying they do I'm not saying I'm not
I'm not saying it don't sue me I'll sue
you I will sue you
too I'll sue you too but I'm saying give
me this IP I hope my agent is on this
but they always yes me to
death they always yes me to death these
people and then send me to Reno they're
like you're going to
Reno which I have no problem with but
what I'm saying is finally a story
that makes sense for Tim Dylan to to be
the steward of I bring in great
writers every I'll bring in I will bring
in I will make this thing perfect this
will be and we'll Telegraph it with
meaning that art now we need to tell you
what the themes are because you're so
stupid out there not you but you are so
dumb out there that we need to tell you
what's happening during the thing nobody
in the in in girls I watched the pilot
of that Lena Dunham you know for all her
other issues is did a great job with
that show and the Pilot's very funny and
all these things like white privilege
you know whatever economic privil
whatever you want to talk about right
they're all in there misogyny they're
all in there but nobody's telegraphing
it nobody's telling you what is
happening moment to moment because back
in the early days of 20110 or whatever
that was 2012 People trusted something
to convey a message without banging you
over the head but I won't do that with
this I will bang you over the head right
before they kill the kid they will go
and we'll get away with this cuz we're
white men and then they do I will tell I
will bang you over the head with the
message you will it will not be lost
give me the IP give me the IP it will
not be lost on you it will not be lost
everyone that sees this will know
exactly what it is I fun but with this
and I know I'm being factious but I'm
not cuz I want the IP I'm dead serious
about this this is my ticket and not
listen don't misunderstand this is a
tragedy and I'm calling for that I want
these kids to go to jail and convert to
Islam season two but no I want them all
in jail death penalty whatever they got
over there death penalty for them but
for me the intellectual property rights
to the story because it is a a story
that does teach lessons to all it
teaches lessons to
all that's where I am on that
and we don't know what's going to happen
we expect something this week do we know
from our inside sources do we know do we
think anyone big is going down this week
yes yes now so that's where we are with
it and I'm like I
said something's up down there I don't
know what it is I don't know what it is
or why
I have the who I have the what well I
don't have the what I have the I don't
have the how
even but here's the thing let let's
watch a little bit of this who is this
this is the police chief of what is this
dump called again
Gilbert and they're calling this one of
the greatest places to live uh yeah it
was have they seen the Hamptons no this
is in the In-N-Out or oh no I thought I
thought he was giving the speech from
the in- andout out uh we're going to
watch this cop now I would
cast uh you know someone great I would I
just H I have the people in my head
already I have the
mother not that anyone's I'm thinking of
anyone in particular because I'm not but
I have the mother I have everybody I
have everyone cast we're going into
Netflix finally with confidence here I
am here I am here I am and I will March
in okay with the Nation of Islam who
will write the script to this I will
March in with the Nation of Islam okay
and I mean it will look wild when I walk
in but we will sit down with the Nation
of Islam who are writing the script of
this thing with the white killers and if
they don't give me a check if they don't
write me a check after I walk in with
the Nation of Islam okay but pro-jewish
a very small sect of the Nation of Islam
who's pro-jewish and writing this with
me this is a very curated group of
nation their Nation of Islam Black
Nation of Islam very pro-israel maybe
black Israelites but they're also
screenwriters and they're coming in
Netflix with me get ready and I'm
walking in we're pitching Gilbert goons
and and it's going to be called the
goons or something the goons the desert
goons something like that
and if they don't if if I can't get that
going then what good I mean then then I
mean we call the whole thing off if I
can't if I can't make this if I can't
make this show about the white killers
and their Rich [__]
parents by Arizona
standards making this
happen let's watch this
police chief yeah he he finally did a
press conference today for the first
this is his press conference the chief
of police in uh
lizardville did everything we could with
that investigation uh as far as
following off the leads the one thing I
mentioned that we could have gotten that
video out sooner to the public to try to
identify Chief soberg frequently reading
from notes as he answered questions
about why more arrests haven't been made
in several other violent attacks we hear
of a broken trust from the community
concern with who has been arrested and
who hasn't people come to us and I want
to say for a minute I just want to say I
am really
truly like impressed with the community
of people down there but the IP is
mine and who hasn't people come to us
and ask is there a cover up what is your
response to that I got two responses for
you one
second a cover up question
yes so reference your first uh question
about is there a cover up absolutely not
there's no cover up as for the group The
Gilbert
goons well well I believe
um as for your first question there's no
cover up well there's that we're GNA
leave that there I'm just letting
everybody know that it is my it is my
movie it is my series it is something
that I will make I will go in there and
this is my this is my time
mhm this is my story and my
time that's what it is time for justice
for for the child that was killed
tragically it is also time for a little
Justice For Me finally it's a little
Justice for me now finally to go into
HBO and get some uh get some attention
get a check written for something so
it's Justice all around it's all around
justice for all with this this is mine
if I swear to Christ Adam McKay or any
of them appat any of them
this is mine this needs to be mine
now Beverly Hills a town that
um
evokes I don't know some maybe negative
thoughts from people out
there uh some positive thoughts as well
Beverly Hills 90210 was a great show
when I was growing up people liked it it
was about Dylan and his sister Brenda
and their friend Steve Ian zering who
was beaten by bikers the other day in
Beverly Hills right or somewhere o with
Ian zering uh who played Steve in a
Beverly Hills
90210 was beaten by bikers in
Hollywood the other
day uh yeah um Tory
Spelling who played Donna whose father
Aaron Spelling was a creator of the
show Andrea played by a
Gabriella ceras who is the head
of sag for a while Brian Austin
Green Jenny G
Kelly it was a I preferred Melrose Place
to this
but I was in the
minority many people love Beverly Hills
902 and0 it was about rich
good-looking
people and it was the first one of those
shows after that it was Dawson's Creek I
mean then it was just Gang Busters it
was a very influential show teenage soap
operate it gave rise to that ya young
adult genre that has been a gold mine
in Hollywood Beverly Hills 902 and
that's probably the most well-known show
about Beverly Hills I can't think of
anything else that was when I grew up I
only knew of Beverly Hills through that
show that's many people right and then
you grow up and you realize that it is a
very very uh Rich wealthy Enclave of
California and of course now you have
the Real
Housewives Beverly Hills there's a
franchise a Rodeo Drive where a lot of
shops are it's a little city in the
middle of California in the middle of
Los
Angeles it's not where they have any uh
Hollywood stuff though there's no
studios
there there's no uh it's like a lot of
lawyers it's a lot of doctors a lot of
plastic surgeons a lot of restaurants
it's where rich people live a lot of
foreign money a lot of Persians a lot of
carpet stores well a lot of them are in
West Hollywood but
uh Beverly Hills is not like where
actors live or or if there are any
actors left but it's none of that it's
just it's business people lawyers
Persians
whatever and there's two parts of it
there's the flats which is the flat
section and then there are the hills
obviously there are some wild big houses
and
Estates and then there's actually some
you know the slums at Beverly Hills was
a movie about there are some shitty low
rent apartments in Beverly Hills that
people live in mhm it does not have the
highest per square foot real estate
value in La that I that was the Pacific
Palisades probably still is Beverly
Hills values get dragged down by the it
is by the apartments it's kind of
Republican Beverly Hills it's a rep
people talk about it like it's liberal
but it's not it's it's Republicans it's
a lot of Persians that are Republican
and and people that are older the
residents are older right but the
interesting thing about Beverly Hills is
that it gets around a lot of the wacky
things that La does like La will say
vaccine mandate Beverly Hills goes nope
mask mandate Beverly Hills goes
nope all of these
um you
know
laws Ula the Mansion tax where everybody
in Los Angeles if you sell your house
for more than $5 million you have to
give four 4% of it to the government and
that that supposedly is going to be used
effectively to help
homelessness so Beverly Hills goes no
nope nope so Beverly Hills is this
little
Enclave that and Malibu does this too
Malibu's out by the beach and Malibu
goes no to a lot of this no defunding of
the cops you know all that
stuff however
Beverly Hills just got got a little bad
news in the most La way ever by the way
because the judge who delivered this
ruling and so here's what the ruling is
they want Beverly Hills have affordable
house now by the way I don't know why
this and I'm dead serious here they want
Beverly Hills to have affordable housing
for poor people I couldn't think of a
worse place to be poor than Beverly
Hills I'm 38 I was poor till I was 34
not poor like don't come at me and be
like you weren't real did you live in
apple eight that's not what I mean
that's not what I mean I mean that I for
the 10 years I did comedy before I
succeeded on any level I didn't have a
lot of money that you know what's fun
when you don't have a lot of money
living in New York City grabbing dollar
slices of Pizza smoking cigarettes with
your buddies on a roof that's what's fun
and I'm sure there's tons of other
college towns and old houses you know
what's not fun place to live when you're
poor Beverly Hills there's nothing
worse than getting a $19
smoothie when you're broke in Beverly
Hill I don't know other than if this is
exclusively from Maids if that's what
the affordable housing is for like maids
and and people that work in Beverly Hill
but if you're just regular broke not
like you just got to America
yesterday I mean like you're just
regular broke and you're you're you're
not you know things are like it's not
the place to be I genuinely don't know
why it's a good idea to put affordable
housing in one of the the richest cities
in the world is it a is it we're making
a point are making a point going like he
hey hey millionaires your fund's over
here here they come but are we thinking
it all about the people that are down on
their luck or or maybe they're not down
on their and by the way what is Beverly
Hills version of affordable housing
going to be for people that make 400
Grandin a year is that what we're
talking about I don't think that's what
we're I think we're talking
about lowincome housing loow income for
people that have low incomes
right and I know that it's like it's a
we're we're we're there's there's this
thing like well what you know because
everybody talks about the idea that like
people that have a lot of
money should have to have lowincome
housing in their Community but if your
entire little city that you've created
is exclusively by and for rich people
it's kind of a shitty place to live if
you're broke it it's actually like not
that fun so I'm not understanding the
wisdom of having affordable housing in
Beverly Hill and and by the way I'm open
to I'm not like everyone now like
they'll be like oh you're
constantly you siding with the rich
people I'm just fleshing out why this
makes sense or doesn't make sense it's
the same thing I said to my jet broker
Durk I said I don't
understand no this is what they've
decided they've decided that they're
going to
Halt construction permits in Beverly
Hills they going to Halt them until
there's more affordable housing until
there is more affordable housing what
that means is that you cannot do a any
any permit we're not talking about ju
you building the big uh 20,000 I'm
talking about a bathroom a
kitchen the
stairs the deck anything you might need
you cannot get a permit to do
construction on the potentially
dangerous situation in your house until
there is more
affordable housing for the poor people
of Beverly
Hills follow all the logic here I'm I'm
the potholes in this are large enough
you can't even drive a car down the
street but fine California and the and
the judge the judge who delivered this
ruling the judge who delivered and by
the way this could also be you own an
apartment building in Beverly Hills and
you want to repair something that your
tenants have complained about correct me
if I'm wrong you can't you couldn't get
a permit to do that right correct no
permits no permits so to the people
living in Beverly Hills in apartments
that might be broke and not living in up
to code or good apartments that their
landlords need to fix for whatever
reason they can also not get permits
until there's more affordable housing I
don't know if that means like green
lighting the affordable I don't know if
they need to see the ground are we
breaking ground I don't I don't know
what needs to happen the judge Curtis a
kin blocked the city from issuing all
building permits except for new
residential development as a penalty for
Beverly Hills failure to approve a
sufficient blueprint for affordable
housing Curtis a
kin now who is who is this judge decent
looking young Asian-American
male
now okay like anybody who should be
weighing in
on local
politics he was a contestant on Big
Brother the
judge who is
now presumably getting back at the
producers of Big Brother by telling them
they cannot renovate their kitchen
island in Beverly
Hills this ju this this radical judge
because it is radical to say nobody can
do anything was a contestant on Big
Brother California is burning in exactly
the way it should it is being taken down
by ex reality stars it is being shredded
and by the way California and Victor
Davis Hans have talked about this
recently the only reason they can get
away with the level of insanity they get
away with other than the weather which
is not even that great everyone goes the
weather the weather the weather's
fine but the reason Reon they can get
away with it is because they have this n
trillion doll market cap in Northern
California where all the tech companies
are that's why people like Nome and all
these people are celebrities right like
uh uh you know Gavin and uh and
Feinstein and Pelosi they celebrities
because they're backed by all this big
Tech money they never lose and they're
allowed to kind of get away with wacky
stuff that people in New York couldn't
get away with um because again all of
that is the largest consolidation of
wealth ever in the history of the world
and it's in Northern
California um to they can get away with
stuff that you just couldn't get away
with if you didn't have that so this
judge Curtis a kin can we find uh any of
him speaking whether it's on Big Brother
or not is there any this is a Curtis a
kin can you imagine there can you
imagine your you cannot renovate your
home because the
judge who was a contestant on Big
Brother do you want big brother is not
allowing you do you want him on big
brother or do you want him just talking
because we got
both let's see him on Big Brother let's
see the origin story I want to
know where this guy comes from who is
this guy not that I think I'm so great
but the show is about people we we are
those people it's not about the game
show anymore mankind is bigger than the
show yeah it's what we would do to one
another whatever and so even if he's
wrong about what the premise
fundamentally was in the beginning there
is something that we do have is it's a
2-8 Street of negotiation I suppose the
I mean California really deserves that
this guy was he elected uh no he was
appointed by Jerry Brown he was
appointed okay and he's the judge here
does he give any rationale for this
ruling uh
other than the fact that he's like you
know where broke people really want to
live the Beverly Hills they want to buy
a $80 cheese at the cheese
shop and then by the way the LA Times go
up to that because the LA Times knows
what they're doing they go in Beverly
Hills no kitchen remodels or pool grados
as judge orders of building moratorium
over lack of affordable housing so again
it's like there you know everyone just
uh fixing their pool Grotto and uh you
know hitting homeless people with a
stick
go by the way and ask who this is
helping go to the people on fentol
living on the street and ask them if
they're if they feel better that no
one's doing a pool gr it's the most
insane
thing oh here's his logic right here he
here's his logic read his Logic the
judge noted that Beverly Hills is
counting on medical office buildings and
car dealerships to convert to
housing so like that the AI dealership
is apparently going to potentially
become an apartment all these defunct
car dealerships along Wilshire Audi
dealership's going to become an
apartment for lowincome people in
Beverly
Hills part of it that's that that's the
plan we have
110,000 people on the street many of
them writhing in pain because they
haven't hit had their fix because
they're addicted to drugs which we just
let come come in and whatever we buy
them we make them whatever and the
response to that the with a straight
face is to convert the Audi dealership
to seven
apartments and if not and if that
doesn't happen soon if that doesn't
happen now you cannot fix a crack in
your
deck this is the it's the stupidest
idea can you imagine people that are
broke going I live in Beverly Hills now
telling their friends I live in Beverly
Hills go man you turned it around not
really I'm in this low-income housing
thing it kind of sucks it used to be an
Audi dealership they keep knocking on
our doors and making us pee in a cup is
that what's going to happen by the way
is it going to be like enforced like is
that what is that the kind of the game
here maybe I'm all for low-income
housing by the way I'm over people that
don't have money being able to live
places I'm I'm not saying that it's what
I'm saying is
that I don't understand the wisdom of
putting them in the most expensive city
City in the one of the most expensive
cities in the country other than getting
back at it's not like there's a
tremendous amount of resources right
there for them that can be accessible
what are they going to start do what do
they want to live near plastic surgeons
is that important when you're when you
don't have a lot of money is it
important that you live near plastic
surgery that's what Beverly Hills is
offering plastic
surgeons is that what people want
somebody said when you force too many
sardines into a sardine can you end up
with something inedible well they don't
really know how to the people in Beverly
Hills don't know how to oppose this they
really don't know how to say like they
need to listen to what I'm saying do you
hear what I'm saying does anyone how
about that can anyone listen to what I'm
I know people a lot of influential
people listen to this show this Show's
not the biggest show but it is a lot of
very rich influential people people that
are on presidential campaigns people
like the show that have a brain in their
head that is what it is
now listen to what I'm oppose it like
this don't call people sardines I'm
giving you the blueprint of how we can
get this out of there if you listen to
me I'm not for I'm my I I go I'm around
that Audi thing a lot I'm telling you
how we get rid of this the right
way who said the Sardine thing who's
white why is white speaking said white
of the municipal League Thomas White
Municipal that's who they send out to
oppose this someone named Thomas White
of the municip literally this is the
quote this is the quote you have too
many sardines it uh turns into a too
many sardines in a sardine can it
becomes like uh inedible uh inedible
said white that's what it says in the
new LA Times said
white I'm telling you people the facts
and the
truth lowincome
housing here's the other thing people
are not going to want to
admit and people are gonna get mad at me
when I say this and God God forbid I
tell a lie here because I'm not telling
a lie poor people really like other poor
people this is true this is actually
true they get
along they get along they raise the cars
you see them on YouTube they get
along and it's weird like are they gonna
like it I don't think they're gonna like
it if you took a bunch of Daytona Beach
white trash and drop them off at the
Colony Hotel in Palm Beach they're not
going to like it because they want
burgers and tits out waitresses and
stuff and it's there's nothing wrong
with that it's just everybody needs to
do what they
enjoy
I don't think low-income people want to
live in Beverly Hill I'm I'm my
opposition to this is actually for them
not for me I want them I want as many
lowincome people in Beverly Hills as POS
when I'm in Beverly Hills I look around
and I go you know what this place
needs and by the way there's already
enough um scumbags there because it's
big for tourism so a lot of deags are
already there they're already there
there's the Cheesecake Factory they
already go they walk down Rodeo Drive
with their F they're already there we
don't have to house them we don't have
to they can't we don't have to let them
sleep in the Audi
dealership they got to go home we got to
give lowincome Californians a reasonable
rational route to a life and it is not
shoving them in a in a luxury car car
dealership in Beverly Hills that's not
the answer so that they can do what
exactly coffee is $18 what can they do
there get a tit lift a Brazilian butt
lift get a face lift get their neck cut
open that's all people are doing in
Beverly Hills is getting their next
stapled together and getting pills from
their doctor that's all it is a town of
people getting pills filling
prescriptions that's all anyone in
Beverly Hills is doing pretending to eat
a salad
and filling prescriptions that's what
they're
doing and now on top of that we're g to
have low-income people that can afford
to do neither they can't afford to enjoy
Beverly Hills to give them a place they
can
enjoy like Gilbert Arizona you enjoy
that there's probably a Chili's chilies
I like chilies it's good you can race
things in the dirt they go fast look how
fast it goes in the dirt
but Beverly Hills to really enjoy it you
have to be filling a prescription have
you ever heard the sound of pills in a
bottle as they get wrapped tightly up in
a nice little thing and handed to you
your legal drug of choice and you get
right into your car and you and you put
your hands on that heated steering wheel
and you gobble one of those bad boys
down with a nice feede or an aquapa and
then you sit your [__] ass in the car
and you look both ways and you go right
out on a Beverly Drive with a nice that
chalky pill taste in your throat and
then you go home and you stare at
yourself in the mirror and see if your
neck stapling
worked that's what Beverly Hills is you
cannot put a bunch of people that are
not ready for that life they're not
ready for that
life they're not ready poor people are
actually very lovely and Earnest many of
them and they actually are good people
it's it's kind of cruel to force them
into this den of
snakes and this is the track the people
got to take listen to
me this is what you got to go out there
and say go we are
bad and we don't want to ruin their
lives by having them here sleeping in
our Audi
dealership just come out and go we want
the H we want the low-income housing but
we we want to make it good for them so
we got to take some time we don't want
to rush it we don't wna who's the mayor
of Beverly Hills I believe it's a woman
one second who is
it Lily boss get her up let me see this
let me see this
lady can I get a meeting with this woman
of course can I sit down with this
woman look at look at get get her wish
she's holding the
microphone that's right okay she's had
some she's had a couple of things done
hasn't she and they look good get her in
the green outfit get her when she's in
the green outfit
yeah the woman this is the mayor of
Beverly Hills she's dressed like money
she's dressed like she looks like a $100
bill she's
dressed Lily baby ly ly ly ly ly ly ly
boss boss Lily the boss ly boss ly boss
ly
boss ly my ly my ly love my ly lady love
you got to go out there and you got to
say of course we want to enrich our
community with spumps
but we have to do it the right this is
what she should do she get out grab the
mic and go listen to me I'm Lily Lily
boss the mayor of Beverly
Hills every night I look at at my
husband and tell him to get off his
phone and I tell him when I look deeply
into his eyes I say
husband Farhad whatever his name is I
say listen to
me I want more lowincome residents in
Beverly Hills but it has to be done
perfectly and every night we discuss it
because he's a property developer and
every night we disc discuss how to do it
how we can do it properly for example
here's a thought Here's a thought look
at what Hamas has done with
tunnels 450 miles of tunnels I think the
New York Times
said are you telling me we cannot build
lowincome housing in
tunnels under Beverly Hills like Hamas
did can we not do that some people that
are friends with Hamas live in Beverly
Hills in very big homes can we ask those
people how it's done is it impossible
that we can't build underground tunnels
for low-income
people that also have skylights where
they can
see is that a bad idea no no it's
not it's one of my many good and that's
what Lily should
say Lily should say that in tragedy
there is opportunity
in researching the Hamas Terror Network
after the tragic events of October 7th
me and my husband were stunned at the
intricacy of the tunnel system we
believe that we can accomplish something
like that in Beverly Hills a fully
functioning Subterranean City for
lowincome residents that has all the
things that they need check cashing
places places where they fry food
tattoos that you can go get with your
children all in a tunnel Network an
intricate tunnel Network dug underneath
Beverly
Hills it's not a bad idea not a bad
[Music]
idea people are all up there into this
timothi Shalom they say he's a houthi a
fighter he's hot they say it looks like
shalomay fighter with terrorists on
hijack [__] banned from Tik Tok after
going viral as hot hothy
pirate let him be hot on Tik Tok he's
going to die we're going to kill him
nobody's going to you're not gonna win
against America stop stop aoui the
yemeni Pirates are gonna win let him be
hot for the last few minutes of his
life let him be attractive he is very
attractive I'm sure he's all death to
America that's not turning any of us off
by the way people are going to flick
their Bean to you and jerk their [__]
to you all night you can [__] say
death to America all you want it doesn't
matter we are still gonna [__] whack
it to the idea of you [__] us on that
boat now does he say anything does he
talk I think he might but this is a
video of is it death to
America uh no you want to just watch
this one let's watch
[Music]
it how great is it by the way that we
this is the way you
turn you turn these yemeni Fighters into
gay sex
symbols that's how you win the war MH uh
because they become too embarrassed to
fight of course there's only one
good-look many of them are probably a
mess yeah let's see let's see the rest
of the
[Music]
video by the way is it is like I'm I'm
not trying to be critical here but like
is this what terrorism is
now because like when I grew up
terrorism was actually like killing
people like this is just you're I'm
you're hot on a
boat is that what terrorism is now
you're just going to be hot on a boat
aren't like what's what we're supposed
to cringe when we see what you're doing
we're not supposed to start masturbating
when we watched a terrorist video when I
was growing up we'd be like Jesus [__]
oh my God Daniel Pearl any of that stuff
this video only makes me want to jerk my
[__] that's not good
terrorism terrorism is supposed to not
make you want to flick your be it's
supposed to make you very disgusted and
scared and terrifi I am the opposite of
scared when I see this if this is what
we're up against Twinks in the ocean
that's what we're up against these
people people are so dead they're so
dead we just bomb them with [__] fat
people one person that lives in
Cleveland could take out that whole boat
and
crush this uh let's see the rest of this
does he say anything does he do anything
I think it's just like a thirst trap not
even a death to America he's doing a
thirst trap he's about to
[Music]
die well it it nothing's like it used to
be I'm getting to that age now where I
look at the world and I long for when
things made
sense chiotti
[Laughter]
Depp terrorism used to be about cutting
people's heads off or lighting them on
fire not just sitting there and being
hot on Tik Tock in a
boat there's no values anymore no one
has any
values we used to respect our
terrorists yes we created them and
funded them but who cares they were
important to the whole
narrative we respected them because they
kept doing increasingly crazier
[__] the bombings the beheadings the
burnings now they're
hot this isn't going to work we're
falling in love with them but maybe that
is their new plan to just be hot just be
hot and sexy maybe they've gotten as
lazy as we are we're the lazy ones you
guys are out working that's why we give
you all this
money our enemies have to work that's
the rules we give you the money and the
weapons you go do heinous [__] and then
we go kill all of you and then when that
uh runs out we give more of you money
and we then we and everybody back to one
lights camera action rolling Gilbert
goons day wise sit right in the
chair right in the chair sound and I'm
hello hi cut Hi how are you put the
Iguana on the left of him I want yeah I
understand I'm tip because I have a
cactus on the right I want an iguana on
the left are iguanas not in Arizona
they're not it's more of a Miami thing
is there a li well what is the lizard
with the beard the when the beard goes
out like the dragon can we do that
because let's end on that because we
have we do a closeup of the kids and
then we end on the because the beard
takes you you know what I mean takes you
really into it where we're trying to go
into the heart of it I me I own the I'm
the whole story this whole thing that's
what I do okay no no no I respect
everyone we all have jobs I got it we
all have jobs we all have jobs that's
great
Sarah snook as the mom from succession
how about that Sarah [__] snook we
attach her sioban Roy one of the greats
Sarah snook we attach as the
mom as the mom of one of the
goons she could do an American accent
she's a [__] killer snook is on board
look at her this is the mom of the Goon
Sarah
snook um
for the one of the goons uh we got to do
like a
[Music]
uh who's a Gilbert goon
type [__] somebody from Euphoria do the
no they're all 40 do the kid from the
mick that uh Thomas bar Barba the mick
kid yeah that guy but he's older now go
to that go to go down down down down
down Gilbert goon yes Gilbert goon big
and big Gilbert goon that's we cast him
he's in go down go down there's more go
to with the hat right there there it is
Gilbert goon there we I'm telling you I
will have a show here that will be
amazing amazing amazing timd comedy.com
where can you find me timeland
comedy.com where can you see me San
Antonio this weekend next week weekend
whatever weekend San Antonio Dallas
Atlanta St Louis Indianapolis West nyak
just announced Levity Live great Club
trying to get some fun Clips Boston
three shows at the Wilbur almost sold
out probably adding a fourth Foxwoods
Chicago we're going back to the Improv
you know why because it's a lot of the
same material from Chicago Theater I
just love Chicago and it's an hour
outside it's shamberg it's kind of a
different Market we're just going to be
having a lot of fun those shows Chicago
is one of my favorite places to do
comedy Dania Beach Florida at the Dania
Beach Improv which I believe is around
Fort Lauderdale I'll be staying in Palm
Beach um Tula India Phoenix W Phoenix
Atlantic City New Jersey timd delc
comedy.com I will tell you this folks
again I had just visited uh Palm Beach
there is it is my home spiritually sadly
not physically I don't have the funds
but it is my spiritual
home I've never felt
at more at peace than I do
there I I and when you observe me there
don't do you feel I'm at peace yeah it's
like your natural habitat I I've never
been in a place where I I it every it
just clicks it
works It just
fits
and and that's the thing it's just
something nice about it you know
something nice about it and
um you won't hear that you won't hear
Palm Beach judge says no renovations
until affordable you
know there's no judge in Palm Beach it
was on Big
Brother G so many people stop me in the
street and they say
um do you know how I can help myself
from the government
and I
gow and they go not just the government
spying but private companies harvesting
my data online selling it and then using
it to Market me
things I go I gotta be honest with you
this is a pretty common problem they go
really I go yeah I go have you heard of
expressvpn and they said no I said
listen when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers can see every
single website you visit they can
legally sell this information without
your consent to to add companies and
Tech Giants who use your data to Target
you and they go that's what I'm [__]
saying I said you can go to all the
Netflix's in all the world Korean
Netflix you're
in because your VPN disguises where you
are scrambles your IP address there are
things on UK Netflix you want to watch
but you can't now you
can this is when they start losing their
minds it's easy to
use fire up the app and click one button
it works on all your devices phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected I love it I use it and
everyone I've ever met uses it and
everyone I've ever met who hasn't used
it sadly is no longer with
us secure your online activity by
visiting
expressvpn.com Dillan today that's
expressvpn.com
timj Dillan and you can get an extra
three months free expressvpn.com Tim
Dillan but to my brothers and sisters in
Beverly Hills stay
strong
stay
strong it's a KN fight out there as as
has been said to me about other places
um and I hope everybody gets the I hope
everything works out for
everybody I want I want and it feels
like it won't happen but my birthday is
coming up and I want Israel and
Palestine for my birthday to just do a
just
chill do a big concert get jelly roll
and have fun have a little fun godamn
it come see me on the road good night